hey everyone
i hope you've all had a safe and happy
thanksgiving
uh as you all know we we are in the
middle of a major surge
uh in covet cases uh so i'm grateful to
dr
thaucci both for his leadership so far
during this pandemic but
also for joining us today to discuss
where we go from here
and how you can all stay safe and we're
also going to spend a lot of time
discussing potential
vaccines and all of your questions
around those
so for those of you who are not familiar
dr fauci is our nation's
leading infectious disease expert who
runs the the national
institute for allergies and infectious
disease so thank you dr fauci for
joining today
and i'm hoping that maybe you can start
off by giving us your sense of the
current trajectory right there are
almost
200 000 new reported cases in the u.s
every day now
um and that may undercount some cases
that are not reported
so where are we in this and what do you
think uh
the overall infection rate and
trajectory looks like at this point
well mark thanks for that question it's
important because it really we're in a
very precarious situation
uh when you look at the numbers almost
every day
either breaks a record or ties a record
um
of cases uh to have a baseline of
between one and two hundred thousand
cases a day
is extraordinary when you look at the
number of deaths they're between
1000 and 2000 we're now over 90 000
hospitalizations the total of the
outbreak is
over a quarter of a million deaths 266.
000 deaths and over 13 million cases
if you ask and you did about the
trajectory
when we had the spring uh
in march and april when
it was dominated the outbreak by the
northeastern corridor particularly the
new york metropolitan area
the slope of the curve was like this
when we got to the early summer
when the southern states tried to open
the economy
and did it in somewhat of a disparate
way we had a surging of
cases in florida georgia
texas southern california and arizona
and the slope was still like this our
baseline was between
40 and 60 000 cases a day
what we're seeing now which is a
confluence of
entering into the cooler months of the
late fall in the early winter
the holiday season where people
congregate on indoor
settings wonderful innocent things that
we do
socially with our family and our friends
having meals and congregate settings
the slope has done this it's on an
increment
that is almost exponential which is
really
dangerous situation to be in
particularly
as we get deeper and deeper into the
cold
months of the winter and we have the
christmas holiday coming up
so you ask a reasonable question the
trajectory
is we're in a very precarious position
so the obvious question is
what are we going to do about it you
mentioned vaccines we'll talk about that
later
that's on the horizon but before we get
vaccines
we're going to have to deal with
something that is
very you know i mean it's literally
record-breaking every day
so what we have is maybe five
fundamental public health measures
that are pretty easy to implement
uniform wearing of masks
keeping physical distances six feet if
you can possibly do that
avoiding crowds and congregate settings
particularly
indoors and that means typical things
like gatherings and restaurants
gatherings at homes
where people other than the immediate
family unit are together
the reason we say that is that the
infection
in the community level now is driven by
people who are without symptoms
because about 40 to 45 of the people who
are infected
have no symptoms and we know that a
substantial proportion
of the people who get infected get
infected from someone
who doesn't even know they're infected
that's one of the reasons for the
uniform wearing of masks
i wear a mask not only to protect myself
but prevent me
from infecting you and you wear a mask
for the same reason for me
the other thing is to try as an extent
possible to do things
outdoors preferentially over indoors
that's going to be tough when you're
dealing
with states in the northeastern part the
central part of the country i mean
you're not going to be doing many things
outdoors in december in minnesota
that's for sure but we need to try and
do that as best as possible
if we do those five things with hand
washing
being the fifth thing we know when you
have
one state next to another and you have
disparate implementation
of public health measures where one
state does not uniformly wear masks
doesn't close bars has full capacity in
restaurants and compare it
to a similar demographically and
geographically similar
state that does all those things that
has
uniform wearing a mask maybe even a
mandate
doesn't have bars open has limited
capacity in restaurant
and essentially has a public health
mandate
the difference in how that that
increment goes is this versus that
so there's something that we can do we
have it within our power
to get ourselves through this until we
ultimately get a vaccine which would be
you know as we say help is on the way
but it's not here yet
so we can do these things and we can
prevent an even further
escalation i referred to it on one of
the sunday shows
yesterday as a surge superimposed upon a
surge
what we've done now with thanksgiving
mark
we're not going to see the repercussions
of that
for two to three weeks from now so
because of the travel
and people congregating for meals etc
you don't see any difference for a day
two three five days
you see the difference two or three
weeks from now which would put it
right at the time that people would be
traveling for christmas
so all things considered we're not in a
good place
and i've heard you talk about
uh different age groups that are being
affected potentially more than
um is the conventional wisdom at this
point um
what are you seeing in terms of the
different groups that this is affecting
at this point
yeah you know in the beginning mark uh
and that's one of the things about this
outbreak that people have to realize we
need to be humble and realize
that at any given time particularly
early on we don't know all the answers
and there was a rather i think almost an
artificial dichotomy
that young people do really really well
they get infected most of them have no
symptoms they don't get into trouble
the elderly and those with underlying
conditions
they have a higher incidence of the
severe
consequences which lead sometimes to
hospitalizations
intensive care and account for most of
the deaths
generally speaking that's true
but what we're starting to see now as we
get months and months into it
that a substantial proportion of the
people that are getting hospitalized
are between 40 and 59 years old
that's not an elderly 80 year old person
and those people can get into trouble
and in fact i have to tell you just
three days ago on friday when i made
rounds in my
hospital at the nih in the clinical
center we went in
with a man who was 37 years old
who had serious lung involvement and
right now it's touch and go so this idea
if i'm in my 30s my 40s my 50s i'm okay
be careful it's not the usual situation
that you get someone that age clearly
overwhelmingly
it's the conditions at any age
and the elderly they get into serious
trouble but there are enough people
who are younger who get into trouble
that we can't just blow this off
as being insignificant for the younger
people
and what do we know at this point um
about the long-term effects of this i
mean there are certainly those who
the long-haulers who have symptoms for
three months or four months or
i i've seen reports of six months um
and i imagine we're starting to study
some of the long-term
effects of the disease as well um
can you give a summary of what our
current understanding of those
impacts is yeah yeah
that's a good question that often gets
confused mark so there are two types
of post-covered involvement with
symptoms and signs
one of them is the one that you refer to
which we refer to
probably we've got to get a better word
for it long haul is but that's what most
people have been
calling it are individuals who either
had symptoms stayed at home for a week
or two
at fever aches a little shortness of
breath or even people who've been in the
hospital
who've you know had stays in the
hospital and come back who clear the
virus from their body
so the virus is no longer there and yet
maybe 20 25 of those people and we got
to get the number
more correctly because it hasn't yet
been studied as well as it should be and
we will be doing that
that these people have an unexplainable
symptom complex that seems to be
consistent
among them without any laboratory data
to indicate why they may be feeling that
way
excessive fatigue shortness of breath
whereas people
who are good shape athletes have
trouble climbing a flight of stairs
sleek disturbances
what's called dysautonomia where you get
temperature fluctuations where you feel
flushed
and something called brain fog another
unfortunate word
which really means they have difficulty
concentrating and focusing where you're
looking at a computer screen
and you just can't focus on what you're
doing
that's the thing we're seeing now and
that could last from weeks to months
there's another kind of effect
that is quite well documented
with laboratory data for example if
someone goes in the hospital with kovid
they get difficulties breathing they get
intubated
and put on a ventilator they get
pneumonia when they recover
because they have such damage to their
lungs or sometimes to their heart
or to their kidney it may be months and
months and maybe even longer because we
don't know yet
because we've only been doing this for
less than a year
where they have organ system dysfunction
that is residual
maybe indefinitely so the idea that
you get infected you either get no
symptoms
or you die and if you don't die you're
okay i think that's
really a misperception that they're
going to be a lot of things that we're
going to be following
that people are going to have trouble
even after they recover
yeah that makes sense and it'll be
important to keep studying
so as we head into this holiday season
you went through a number of
um recommendations for people to stay
safe
and it may not be possible to boil this
down to just one thing but but just
i'm curious if you could give people uh
just one piece of advice to keep
safe heading into the holidays what
would that be
yeah that would be uh and this is
doesn't sit well in the in the issue of
how customary christmas and new years
and hanukkah and all that have been uh
traditionally for the family unit
that we're going to have to if i
recommend one thing
is that diminish to the extent
possible travel and keep
gatherings indoor to the immediate
family unit to the extent possible
don't have people who may have traveled
from one state
into what you are a friend of a friend
who brings a friend
try to keep the home environment as much
as possible
confined to the immediate family unit
that seems to be unfortunately mark the
antithesis
of the christmas the new year the
hanukkah season
because she really want to bring friends
the warmth the fireplace the people
sitting down together
unfortunately that's the perfect setup
for people who might have no symptoms
and innocently and inadvertently come
into the home
and infect someone we see that every
time you have a situation
socially that leads to congregate people
getting together so my bit of advice
would be i know as difficult as this is
each family needs to do a risk
benefit determination do i have in my
home
an elderly person a person who's
immunosuppressed maybe
a woman with breast cancer who's on
chemotherapy a man with prostate cancer
on
chemotherapy a child with an immune
deficiency
if you do do you really want to take the
chance of exposing that person
to something that might not allow them
to have future
christmases and new years and hanukkahs
so
i actually think that we need to you
know
this time do things a little bit
differently
yeah i think that makes that makes a lot
of sense and i'm curious to ask the
question
also not just from an individual
perspective what you would do
but from a country perspective but if
there were one change that we could make
as a country
uh to have a significant impact on the
current covid trajectory what do you
think that would be
you know mark it would be everybody
doing things consistently
the same you know as i mentioned so many
times one of the beauties
of our country is that it's the united
states
of america and the federalist approach
that go back to our founding fathers
give each individual state so much
leeway to do things
the way they want to do it which fits
well
for a large country that has demographic
geographic cultural differences which
are the beauty
of the country that works well when you
have
an epidemic a respiratory pandemic
that's as efficient and spreading as
this is
and has such an impact on the health of
the people
you can't have one thing one state one
region doing things one way
another one the other way because what
you do impacts the entire
country so you want to be able to be
part of the process
that diminishes and ultimately crushes
this outbreak
and what we've had historically is that
incredible disparities in how we do
things i mean it's become
masks are good or masks are no good you
know
closing the bars are good closing the
bars are not good
that doesn't work mark we've got to be
able to get control of this outbreak
in a way that's consistent and uniform
so as a nation that would be my
recommendation and of course
let's get it out of the political arena
let's forget this divisiveness
divisiveness in an approach to a public
health problem
is just a recipe for not getting it
right
yeah that makes sense so so i'm curious
what you expect to see
over the next few months especially with
this the incoming biden administration
and i'm curious if you have any insight
into their plans because you know i have
to say
um i i'm personally encouraged about
selection of ron clayne
as chief of staff uh you know people
watching this may not know he was in
charge of the government's response
to the ebola outbreak and i was quite
focused at that of the time and
i thought it was handled quite well so i
think it is a very good sign
that someone with that experience is
being elevated in this administration
but i'm curious if you have any
additional insight into their plans
or or what this is going to mean for
your work at the nih or the work that
has to get done at the cdc or the other
agencies
well your instincts are correct uh mark
because
you know i had extensive experience
with ron claim when he was the
coordinator of the ebola response
during the obama administration and he
is the chief of staff
to president-elect biden and
i know him well in his style and he did
an absolutely terrific job with ebola
uh i haven't discussed in any
substantial detail
about what he is going to be
recommending
for the approach of the new
administration but i know ron
and i know his style and he very likely
do the same sort of thing about having a
coordinator
and and facilitating to bring out the
best
in each agency but in a coordinated way
uh that's what he did with ebola i would
be very surprised if he didn't do it
with covert 19 but he certainly knows
what he's doing and knows
um the ins and outs of how to respond
well uh you and and the rest of the
government have an important job ahead
um i know our team at facebook has
already reached out to the incoming
administration to help
in the covert response in any way that
we can um i think there will be a few
important things that we can do together
uh we're already planning a a push
around
authoritative information on vaccines
which
is probably a good transition to the
main scientific topic that i want to
talk about today
um because there have recently been some
very positive
news on the vaccine front with you know
multiple vaccine candidates including
the ones from pfizer and moderna
have recently gotten some results back
that show that
that these potential vaccines are more
effective i think than most
experts had even expected and without
a significant known safety issues so far
um but given that this is such an
unprecedented situation
but i know that lots of people have
questions about these vaccines and
i think we should spend the majority of
our time today answering a lot of those
questions
so a lot of the questions that i've seen
about the vaccine center on the fact
that some of these
vaccine candidates are fundamentally new
types of vaccines
and they were developed very quickly so
i'm curious what your view on that is
and
maybe you could just walk us through the
process of how we determine
scientifically
that a new type of vaccine is safe um
you know my senses most people may not
be aware of just how rigorous this
testing process
is um so maybe you can take a few
minutes just to walk us through that
yeah well mark we we should probably
start off
by getting people to appreciate that
this has been a process that has been
done extraordinarily
quickly but not at the expense of safety
or of scientific integrity so what we've
seen
with these new platforms and for those
not familiar with this a vaccine type
is referred to as a platform so a
live attenuated vaccine is a platform a
whole killed one is a platform
a solute protein is a platform the
platform
that you're talking about is a messenger
rna platform
which is a highly adaptable
extraordinarily promising
approach to vaccines where you don't
ever
even need to get the virus in your hand
you can just get
a gene sequence of what it is and
plug it into this messenger rna
and inject it into a person and you get
the protein expressed and you have a
vaccine
we adapted we being the field not
necessarily me but part
myself and my colleagues this is the
fruit
of years of fundamental basic science in
improving
platform technology so when people hear
you're dealing with something new and
you did it very
quickly were you cutting corners
is this scientifically adequate and
appropriate
where are we going with it well the
first thing to ensure people
that is the fruit of years and years of
incremental research that has come up
with this new platform that has allowed
us
to do things in a manner of weeks to
months
that a decade ago mark would have taken
years
to do with no sacrifice of scientific
integrity or safety
so that explains the speed what about
the efficacy the efficacy of this
vaccine
was proven in a phase three trials and
there were two vaccines that were
talking about
both with the same platform the efficacy
has been
stunningly good and when i say
stunningly good i mean none of us would
have expected
to have seen a 94-95 percent
efficacious vaccine with no
significant severe adverse events
not only was it efficacious in
preventing clinical disease
when you look at severity of disease and
you compare
the placebo with the vaccine it was
overwhelmingly favorable in preventing
severe disease so now we have a product
that would have taken multiple years to
develop
that now show efficacy and safety
to a very high degree with the potential
of completely transforming this outbreak
so the natural question is well what do
you mean
by safety and efficacy how did you prove
that
did you have pressure from the
government did you have pressure from
the company
well what people need to appreciate
that the clinical trial process that
determined
this high degree of efficacy and safety
was done in tens of thousands
of volunteers the modernity trial
had 30 000 people the fisa trial
had 44 000 people in the trial
and what was shown is that what people
don't understand
is that the data when it's accumulated
to determine if it works
the company doesn't get the data the
government doesn't get the data
an independent data and safety
monitoring board
made up of vaccinologists immunologists
virologists
statisticians ethicists independently
evaluate the data and when they feel the
data
truly show safety and efficacy
then the company gets the data
they look at the data analyze it and
then put in
to the fda for what's called an
emergency use authorization or
ultimately a biological license
application namely approval
the career scientists of the fda
no politicians but people who do this
every day
evaluate the data they then
look at the data together with an
advisory committee that's established
it's the it's the vaccines and related
biological products advisory committee
referred to as verb pack another
independent committee
works with the fda to determine is it
ready
to do what we're going to be doing this
coming month in december
starting to distribute the doses to the
high priority
that entire process mark is independent
and transparent because ultimately all
the data
that are the foundation for those
decisions are going to be made
public and published in a peer-reviewed
journal
so i know there are understandable
questions about
is there something going on to try to
slip this through
you know for one reason or other you can
be absolutely certain that that's not
the case
sorry um yeah that's uh
that's all good to hear um you know one
new type of these
vaccine platforms that you mentioned um
is mrna or messenger rna vaccine and
you know i i personally you know find
this advance
uh potentially very exciting because if
this new type of vaccine works as well
as it seems so far
then it could be possible to build on
top of this advance
um to develop other kinds of vaccines
for future diseases a lot more quickly
and effectively but
i'm curious if you can walk us through
how these types of vaccines work
and why this new type of approach can be
such a positive development
not just in this case but more broadly
potentially
well so the way it works
is that it eliminates so much
of the things that had formally
been tried and true so the standard
classic way of making a vaccine is you
have to
isolate the pathogen in question
whatever that might be a new virus or
what have you
then you have to grow it up efficiently
in either eggs or cells that takes a
long time
it's fraught with things going wrong you
grow it up
then you purify it and you either
attenuate it
to give a live attenuated vaccine or you
inactivate it
to give sort of a killed vaccine that's
the standard way of doing things over
the years
given molecular biological approaches
and the advances in technologies
we've gotten to be much more
sophisticated not requiring
having to grow up the virus with
messenger rna
rna is the molecular means
of coding for proteins so if i want to
vaccinate you mark
with a component of the covid
19 virus the sars cov2 the important
component is that spike protein because
when you look at the virus under
electron microscope you have these
spikes that stick out
that's the reason why you get the word
coronavirus
standing for crown it looks like the
spikes
on a crown well that particular spike
protein
is the thing you want the body to make
an immune response against
so rather than getting involved in
handling the virus what happens
as soon as the virus is discovered the
technology today
allows us to get the full sequence of
the virus in
days as opposed to years so then you
publish the sequence
and anybody in any lab can pull the
sequence out
of the gene that specifically codes
for the spike protein so you don't have
to touch the virus
you go in silico in the computer you
pull out the gene
and you stick it into this messenger rna
now the purpose of messenger rna in your
body is to code for all the different
proteins that your body makes
so now you're going to take an
artificially made
rna you're going to stick this
particular
sequence in and then you inject it into
the body
it goes into a cell and it starts
pumping out
protein so the body sees the protein
and says i think that's the virus
because it's a spike protein
but it isn't the virus it's a harmless
protein
that you made very quickly so
to give the the viewers and the
listeners
uh an example on january
the 9th the chinese put on a public
database
the sequence on the 10th we had a
meeting with my team
that said we're going to take that
sequence we're going to
partner with a company moderna and we're
going to maybe three or four days later
meet and get the vaccine
starting to be made it's very simple
i mean it isn't growing a virus you just
stick it in and bingo you start
making and producing the messenger rna
well about 63 days later 62 days later
we had enough of it to do a phase one
trial
an absolutely world indoor record
to go from the time you get a sequence
to the time you have enough
vaccine to do a phase one trial a few
months
later we were in a phase three trial
and then because there was so much
infection in the community
a couple of months later we started the
phase three trial
on july 27th by the time you got to
august september october
we had enough data so that by the time
we got to november
we said oh my goodness we have a highly
efficacious
safe vaccine that we're now going to
start to administer in december
the technology that allowed that mark is
beyond uh uh unprecedented it's
something
that if you had told me that ten years
ago when we were making
vaccines for different things i would
have told you mark i respect you but
there's no chance in the world that
we're going to be able to do that
and it was done and your point is an
excellent
if we're successful which we're we're
there
we just have to go through the motions
of proving it now with large numbers of
people
that we are able to really crush
a disease like covert 19 the way we did
with smallpox and polio and measles
with this new technology you're
absolutely correct
it's such an adaptable technology
that it would likely transform the way
we look at and make vaccines
so i've heard from a lot of people um
who have questions about a new type of
vaccine
that involves rna or dna um and
and why we can expect that this can be
safe without having any issues down the
line so i'm curious to hear
um you know how you'd explain that
scientifically and your thoughts on on
that concern overall
yeah because we know what happens you
know from a lot of work in the animal
models so
that rna that pumps it out pumps it out
for a very limited period of time enough
to get a good immune response
and then the rna degrades the way rna
generally degrades under most
circumstances so what the fda has done
is that they had not could be going to
consider an eua
until 60 days following
the time that half the people in the
trial have received their last
dose and the reason the 60 days is the
magic number
because when you look at the experience
over decades with vaccines
the intermediate and long-term adverse
events
almost all occur between 30 and 45 days
so if you wait 60 days you cushion it a
little and
overshoot a little and if you don't see
severe events during that time
it's extremely unlikely that you're
going to see severe adverse events
and just to clear up one point and my
understanding is that
these vaccines do not modify your dna or
rna
um so so i think that's that's just an
important point to clarify if i'm
getting anything wrong here of course
correct me but
um but just to make that clear
no uh first of all dna is inherent in
your own
nucleus cell sticking in anything
foreign
will ultimately get cleared messenger
rna
is the messenger it comes from the dna
to the rna
to the protein sticking an mrna
into you it has absolutely nothing to do
with your own dna
or your own rna it's going to perform
its function and then it's
going to be degraded and it's gone it
doesn't
have any imprint on any genetic material
of your own
good well i'm glad we can we can clear
that up um a number of people
have also written in and asked um how do
we get a clear answer on how long this
immunity lasts
but if you're talking about um you know
the effect
going in and then potentially wearing
off um
you know does it look like this is the
type of thing where we're going to need
to get boosters regularly
after the initial two doses um or do we
think that this will be
effective for a long time
well mark you know one of the things
that you have we have to be honest about
in science is that when you don't know
the answer you say you don't know
and i don't know how long the immunity
is going to last with a vaccine
uh when you look at immunity to covid
uh to coronaviruses in the past they're
not lifelong immunity
unlike measles when you get infected
with measles or when you get vaccinated
with measles so we would hope it's at
least
a few years and if it does ultimately
require a booster
fine i think the first step giving the
situation that we're in right now
is to show that it actually works so
i'm hoping that the immunity will be
durable enough to get us through a
couple of cycles
and if it isn't we'll cross that bridge
when we come to it and boost people
so one question that i'm seeing in the
comments are um
you know do the vaccines from pfizer or
johnson johnson for example
have have any known collateral effects
or symptoms
um like this person mentions a fever in
adults or anything else like that
yeah well it is not uncommon mark when
you
when you're dealing with vaccines that
there are immediate effects
and then there are things that are more
significant that might occur
later and that's the ones we spoke about
that you can capture in that
60 day period but with any vaccine
some more than others when you get an
injection of the vaccine you
you induce a response in some people
they don't feel anything others feel an
ache in the arm
some may feel an ache in the arm and
kind of a little chilly feeling almost
like you have a flu-like syndrome and in
a minority of people they'll get a fever
they'll actually get a fever for a day
almost all of this goes away
within 24 or at the most 48 hours
so we have to be honest when we tell
people the
the the the adverse events if you want
to call them
are low-grade they're not serious
they're not prolonged
they're low-grade but to let people
think that you get vaccinated and you
don't feel anything
that's not the case you do what your
body is telling you
by that response is that it's respond
another question that i've heard a
number of times is
you know asking why is it necessary to
store some of these vaccines at such
cold temperatures
and um in in practice
doesn't the fact that some of them need
to be stored at such cold temperatures
make it pretty difficult to distribute
the vaccine
how do you think about that in practice
well there are six candidate vaccines
that the federal government
is involved in either helping develop or
supporting
the trial you know five of them now are
in
either phase three or finished phase
three or coming to the end
not totally finished but coming to the
end of phase three
they vary in what we call their cold
chain requirements some of them as you
mentioned correctly
require very very low temperatures like
minus 70 uh celsius and
minus 90 fahrenheit and others require
just a plain freezer
and some require just being in the
refrigerator it varies
according to the formulation i believe
that the ones that
really require that very stringent cold
if they study it more it likely would
not require it but in the development of
it they did put it under those
conditions that makes it more difficult
for that particular candidate to be
distributed
in a country or an environment that
doesn't have easy access
to cold chain capabilities but
in this country there will be according
to operation warp speed
the capability of doing the kind of
storing that's necessary to do that
that is the pfizer product the moderna
product
is less stringent the j and j
product is even less stringent when it
comes to cold chain
and is going to be a great deal of
variability but you're absolutely
correct
sometimes a given vaccine as good as it
may be
would have to be utilized only in a
circumstance
where you can handle those requirements
where other vaccines
may not require a stringent a cold chain
capability
yeah so you know one thing that i
that i just want to say is and and i
worry about here is that no intervention
is ever going to be perfect
right but just because something isn't
perfect or may have some
uh issues doesn't mean that it's still
not significantly better than not
getting it at all or not trusting it
and it seems like this is a fundamental
question about science these days
um and and i'm curious if
if there's any kind of wisdom that you
would want to share with people about
kind of the perspective on on risk
benefit and thinking through this
well you're on to something there uh
mark and that's something we deal with
in medicine all the time
because when you're dealing with either
the treatment or the prevention of
disease
that you're going to do interventions
and there are no interventions of
anything that don't have some risk
it might be a miniscule risk but it's
nothing
it's it's nothing that is completely
free of risk
you take an aspirin there is a risk for
some people
for an aspirin so the way we deal with
it we deal with what's called
relative risk and risk benefit
relationship so if you look at the risk
the relative risk of an adverse event
with a vaccine and look at the history
of vaccinology
it is one of the safest interventions
that you can do if you look at the
benefit is
to you as an individual and to society
particularly in the context of this
terrible
challenge we're being faced with with
this horrible pandemic that this world
this planet is living through
that an intervention like a vaccine
that historically has very very
little risk the risk benefit ratio
overwhelmingly
but then you gave well wait a minute
some people say well you know this is a
new risk i'm bothered by it a bit i mean
i don't know it i really want an
absolute
safety at all you got to think about the
things that you do
every day the decisions that you make
about
risks that you take getting up in the
morning getting in your car and going to
work
that the benefit of the of
the getting to a job that's going to
support your family
is overwhelmingly better than the risk
that you're going to get into a problem
with driving to work but yet you accept
it i mean it's a
it's a risk that you accept i think what
we have to do
is make sure we get people to understand
that the relative
risk of this compared to other risks is
minuscule
when they understand that they'll
understand that it isn't
zero but it's completely
overwhelmed by the benefit that you
would get
yeah that makes sense so i'm i'm curious
to move on to
uh kind of manufacturing and
availability of the vaccine and i'm
curious what
what do you expect the trajectory of
manufacturing these vaccines will be and
what do you expect most people
will be able to get these vaccines
well if let's talk about the united
states first and then globally
so right now the federal government has
contracted with multiple companies to
make
about 600 million doses of vaccine which
would be good enough for around 300
million people getting vaccinated hence
everyone that you would imagine that
would want to get vaccinated in the
country
would have a vaccine in december
the first of the high priorities which
would likely and it's interesting that
you asked that question now mark
because tomorrow the advisory committee
on immunization practices
is meeting with the cdc to talk about
what the recommendations of the
different tiers
of priority which would likely be a
combination of health care providers
frontline people who take care of
patients as well as those
who are at a higher risk like people in
nursing homes and those
types of situations then as we get into
january
the next year in february and march by
the time
we get to april they would likely have
taken care of all the high priority and
then the general
population of the normal healthy
young man or woman 30 years old who's
got no underlying conditions
can walk in to a cvs or to a walgreens
and get vaccinated i would think as we
get through
april and may that we likely would have
the for those who want to get vaccinated
the overwhelming majority of the people
that want to get vaccinated
the the the challenge is going to be to
convince
people to get vaccinated because if you
have a highly
efficacious vaccine and only 50 percent
of the country gets vaccinated
you're not going to have that umbrella
of protection of herd immunity what you
really want
is one what we have a highly efficacious
vaccine
but you want 75 85 of the people to get
vaccinated
if we get to that point mark and we and
people get vaccinated
by the end of the second quarter of the
year you can have enough protection in
this country
that the pandemic as we know it will be
well well
suppressed below the danger
got it so so more specifically you know
what do you expect the vaccine
availability will look like
you know later this winter and then in
the spring and then by the summer when
do you expect we're going to be at the
point where people
where everyone who who wants um to get
the vaccine is is able to do so
yeah like i said i believe that will be
as we enter
into and get to the end of the second
quarter of 2021.
starting with april and going into may
june july
by that time if people want to get it
they can get it and hopefully
everybody would want to get it good
so a lot of people also want to know you
know
when should they get the vaccine is is
your perspective
that if the effectiveness and safety
data ends up as good as it looks now
then everyone should try to get this as
soon as it's available or
is there more nuance and how you think
that people should think about this
well you know each individual person as
we all know
is different and they have their own
assessment of what they want to do
there will be those people and i believe
it will be heavily weighted
towards the elderly and those who have
underlying conditions
who say i cannot risk getting infected i
want to get it as soon
as i possibly can there are others
that might be young healthy individuals
that say you know
i ultimately want to get it but let me
wait until
20 30 million people have already gotten
it it still
looks like it's really efficacious and
it doesn't look like there's any severe
events
i'll get it i may wait two or three
months but i'll get it
so i think that's going to be the
dichotomy of the people
who really feel that the risk for them
is high enough they want to get it as
quickly as possible
and then others who say i want to
ultimately get it but i don't really
need it right now
got it and do you think that that ladder
approach is fine
for for some people or do you think that
those people are making a mistake
well i think for themselves each
individual person makes their own
individual's
decision i would like to see
the overwhelming majority of the country
vaccinated before we get to the end of
the second quarter
because i would like to see children
adults everyone so that when we get into
the fall
season the children could feel really
safe at going back to school
that teachers can feel safe that they're
not going to get infected
we can get back to the economy being
robust
restaurants can open to full capacity
that's what i'd like to see but you're
not going to see it mark
unless the overwhelming majority of
people get vaccinated
so in that sense i would like to see
the reluctant people get vaccinated
sooner rather than later
if they want to wait a month or so
that's okay that might be in accordance
with the pace of being able to implement
but i don't want them to wait
six to eight to nine months i think they
should do it
within that period of the first two
quarters of 2021.
got it and what what do you think is the
best argument to convince
those people that taking the vaccine
during that time frame
is the right decision for their and
their family's health
well because as long as you're
susceptible
you're part of the problem not part of
the solution
when you're protected you're another
person the virus
can't impact where is if you're
vulnerable even if you don't get a lot
of symptoms
the fact that you've been infected means
you are inadvertently
propagating the outbreak so if you want
to be part of the solution
get vaccinated and say i'm not going to
be one of the people that's going to be
a stepping stone
for the virus to go to somebody else i'm
going to be a dead end to the virus
yeah so there are a number of questions
on the thread about herd immunity
and what percent of our society we
currently believe would have to be
vaccinated for everyone to be generally
safe do we know that what's our current
understanding of that
we don't have a definitive percentage of
that for this disease
yet because we're such not
we know we're novices in this because
we've only been dealing
with it for less than a year 10 months
we have some pretty good information for
other diseases for example measles
which is one of the most contagious
viruses known to man
it has a vaccine that's about 97 to 98
percent effective
in order to get hurt immunity you've got
to stay above 90
of the people vaccinated if you don't
get into the 80s you're going to find
out
the kinds of outbreaks we saw in some of
the communities
in the new york city area a couple of
years ago
with this vaccine and this virus
although i don't know definitively mark
with that
percentages i would imagine it's
somewhere
between 75 and 85
at least interesting
all right so i want to make sure that we
we get a chance to address some of the
social equity issues around vaccine
access as well
um because i know a lot of people would
be willing to pay a lot of money to get
a vaccine sooner but
how are we going to make sure that the
people who need it the most can get it
including vulnerable populations and not
just in the u.s but around the world
and you know there's a question in the
comments here
about whether any high-risk groups will
get a priority
on access to the vaccine
well there's good news answers to all of
your questions so enough vaccine
has been ordered and paid for
to be able to get virtually anybody who
needs a vaccine who wants a vaccine in
this country
i'll get to the global situation in a
moment
in the distribution of vaccine because
once you start distributing it
on day one you don't have enough vaccine
for everybody
so you have to have that prioritization
tomorrow tuesday
the acip the advisory committee and
immunization practices
will be meeting with the cdc to discuss
what the various tiers of prioritization
is
healthcare workers vulnerable people
essential workers school teachers
children on and on and on so
there will be a formula for that
and one of the things we have to do is
to make sure
that the healthcare setting in different
parts of the country with different
demographic groups
doesn't get in the way of them getting
vaccine in an expeditious
manner so that is going to depend very
heavily
on the local public health system
to get the vaccines to the people who
need it
because there certainly will be enough
vaccine for people
we've got to get it to those who need it
and that will be heavily dependent
on the local healthcare delivery system
so if all things work well we know the
doses are going to be delivered
because we have a very good logistics
system
of doing that once it gets delivered to
the places
where it's supposed to be administered
that's another
challenge to make sure it gets
distributed to the people
who really need it that's for this
country
if you really want to be free
of the threat of covert 19
this is a global problem with a global
solution
which means we must be able
as a global community to vaccinate
the entire world and we know from
experience
that certain countries don't have the
capability
of getting making or purchasing
vaccine for their own population
so that's where you get a number of
organizations
including gavi the who
and others to get the developed nations
that are rich nations
to put in to make sure that enough
vaccine
is manufactured to the tune of billions
and billions of doses
so that we can do with covert 19
what we did with smallpox and what we
did with polio
in most countries were on the verge of
eradicating it
and we've done in many respects with
measles
even though we still could do better
with measles
because i have always been of the
feeling
and and and the principle that
that health for the world should not be
determined
by the poorness or the lack of resources
of a country that
we have a moral obligation as a
global community of countries that have
wealth
to make sure that we eliminate the
scourge
from the entire world not only from our
own
provincial environment
yeah i think that that makes a lot of
sense and and i know we're running a
little long here but but maybe
just one or two more questions i'm
curious how you think about
going back to the question around risk
reward um
how do you think different demographic
groups should think about the vaccine
in their own personal plans so for
example the one vaccine expert told me
that he felt
much more strongly that his older mother
gets the vaccine and that then that
younger kids get it because
as you said before his an older mother
would be in a
higher risk group than um that that
potentially could suffer more
but are there other ways that you think
that different demographic groups
um should think about this as we near
the
the availability of a vaccine how
different groups should think about
getting the vaccine well you know
there's strategic
vaccinations for example you made an
interesting
story there that it may be
that the older person doesn't respond
very well and is not protected
and it may be even better to protect the
people
that she grandma is going to come into
contact with
so maybe if you vaccinate the younger
person
you prevent him from spreading the
infection to her
that has been one of the strategies for
a number of vaccines to
vaccinate children even though they
don't get as sick as
the elderly in order to prevent them
from transmitting it to the elderly
that doesn't seem to be the case with
covet 19
but you make a good point i mean i i'm
concerned
more about um vaccines for
for different demographic groups that
normally are reluctant to get vaccinated
like the minority communities we
absolutely
african americans and latinx suffer
disproportionately from covet 19
and yet those are the populations
particularly african-americans
who have skepticism about
government-sponsored
medical programs for good reason
because the extraordinarily tragic story
of tuskegee still looms lodge in the
memory
of some of the older individuals that
pass it down
to the younger generation so we've got
to
reach out and engage them at the
community level
to make sure that that reluctance for
reasons that are understandable
don't prevent people who really need the
vaccine
from getting the vaccine
thanks i i i think that that makes sense
and and doctor i know we are run
short on time um so before
wrapping up i just wanted to ask is
there any are there any other words of
wisdom
that you would like to share with the
millions of people who will
watch this and just want to know how
we're going to get through this
yeah well thank you for giving me that
opportunity mark
we are all living through a terrible
ordeal that is not
over um this issue of
covet fatigue that
really is wearing and tearing at us both
from a personal standpoint
from an economic standpoint people are
suffering
in so many different ways from this
terrible experience we're going through
if you want to call it word of wisdom
it's more word of encouragement
this will end we've got to hang in there
together and take care of each other it
will
end the vaccines are on the immediate
horizon to be starting to be distributed
in the month of december tomorrow's
december the 1st
as we get to the middle and end of
december we're going to start getting
vaccines
distributed all through january february
march
april so rather than getting discouraged
which is an
understandable emotion to a terrible
ordeal that we've all been through
hang in there the end is in sight
it's going to get better and better even
though as as mark pointed out
we're on a really serious inflection of
the curve
that we can do something about blunting
that curve by doing the fundamental
public health measures
that as we do it that curve will bend
it'll start coming down
and as vaccines kick in we're going to
start seeing a dramatic change
so my word of encouragement is that
let's all hang in there together
we are going to get through this
guaranteed
all right dr fauci as always thank you
for this discussion and
i think i speak for most americans when
i say this but
thank you for your leadership and
service to our country through this
difficult period
we appreciate it i i personally
appreciate it
um and i hope you stay good and i hope
to everyone watching this that you all
stay healthy and good and i will see you
all soon thank you mark thank you for
being the opportunity to be with you i
really appreciate it thank you